terreau problématique elle est moins
économique que politique c'est à dire
que la question qui se pose c'est au
fond comment est ce qu'on peut non pas
forcément produire sur le site français
de la pénicilline pour prendre cet
exemple mais comment est-ce qu'on peut
être sûr qu'on aura toujours à notre
disposition de la pénicilline ou
d'autres types de deux molécules entre
guillemets l'entrée de gamme et ça ça
passe essentiellement par une
diversification de nos sources
d'approvisionnement dire que très
clairement beaucoup d'entreprises se
sont fait piéger non pas parce que elle
importait des biens intermédiaires mais
parce que pour le dire clairement pour
mettre les pieds dans le plat
tout était produit en chine est souvent
sur un site unique
prenez le secteur de l'automobile par
exemple peut-être qu'on en parlera plus
tard mais les pédales de francs elles
sont quasiment toutes produites en chine
alors si vous n'avez pas de pédales de
frein et même si vous avez tout le reste
vous pouvez pas mettre sur le marché une
usine automobile
donc voyez en fait ce qu'il faut arriver
à faire mais on va y aller et ça ça va
se faire un peu tout seul en fait ça va
se faire sous la pression des
actionnaires qui veulent pas se laisser
piéger une deuxième fois mais il faut
que les entreprises diversifie davantage
leurs sources d'approvisionnement parce
que là très clairement le fait que la
crise touche la chine
c'est ça le point important les reflets
la crise a touché la chine des sites de
production chinois se sont arrêtés elle
a évidemment un certain nombre
d'entreprises chinoises ou non chinoises
se sont retrouvés complètement piégé
mais vraiment j'ai bon espoir parce que
je pense j'ai vu beaucoup de bien de
leur entreprise je pense que la leçon a
été comprise
[Musique]